[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci ariel et merci dé connaître là
donc on a vu la bande annonce du film
ait eu pour vous rendre hommage
ils sont venus en couple mythique du
cinéma quel couple plus mythiques du
cinéma pour vous du cinéma ou même le
couple mythique à part dans la beaucoup
j'aime roberto rossellini et ingrid
bergman
alors là il ya moitié du public sony cdc
des oiseaux on va faire entrer tout de
suite les premiers est ce que vous vous
rappelez de dirty dancing
[Applaudissements]
à
alors lui c'est censé être patrick
swayze sur la tête de ma mère d'hicham
pizzaïolo pour accueillir baïri bernard
et vous avez tout de suite reconnaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
ça c'est leonardo dicaprio et kate
winslet sur ma vie mon plat lui on
dirait tonton jacques homme qu'est john
dame offert son ami
tha
tout le monde se rappelle de cette
musique
et ceux-là donc là ça sert et chargeurs
et j'adore maintenant il est prié
conducteur de bus à novara 3-1 coupe
c'est batman et catwoman
[Applaudissements]
la soudaine que la susan rice orgueil et
enfin enfin les derniers de la soirée et
est et félix du père noël et de forme
[Applaudissements]
et voilà
on
ga
tout leur est dû
costil
sa jeune
retours forcés pour le meilleur couple
http quoi monsieur van loo
[Musique]